all right
look at oh thank you
i appreciate it that's true love you
can't gin up a crowd they really mean it
i appreciate it i have to start with the
public services we're here in california
we're going to go back there's a drought
like there hasn't been
but
we're going back to emergency levels now
next month yes
watering outdoors only once a week
this does not affect me the plants i
care about grow mostly indoors
also uh
maybe you're happy about this not so big
here in america but around the world
sunday may day that's a huge holiday all
around the world celebrates
workers
and labor labor
by the way did you know they're spelled
differently in england
l-a-b-o-u
there's a u in labor here in america
when there's a u in labor it's because
you just met nick cannon
so
now how many here are old enough to
remember that this weekend is the 30th
anniversary of the la riot was anybody
here for them
let's hear it for the la right now
to to commemorate the occasion
today will smith uh slapped a korean
grocery clerk
[Applause]
i just couldn't believe it's 30 years
that's a very long time 30 years ago
amber heard was [ __ ] in her own bed
but
the big news this week right the big
news elon musk bought twitter twitter is
out
some people like it some i know it's a
kinder some people like it some people
don't elon said everybody's worrying
about nothing twitter is going to remain
a place where something you brain farted
when you were in junior high
can haunt you for the rest of your life
stop worrying
i mean
but he's going to make some changes that
i i think are good he's the first of all
going to get rid of bots
right that's a good thing
he said
we don't want any entity here that are
not real people and uh mark zuckerberg
said why are you making this personal
no did you see what elon did i thought
this was pretty funny tweeted right
after he bought it he said and now i'm
gonna buy coca-cola
so i can so i can put the cocaine back
in
which okay but well
it's all fun and games until hunter
biden gets his head
head's stuck in the vending machine
that's uh
you